smith to inbound back to doncic
dodges pulls up three-pointer bang
bang it's good doncic wins the game at
the buzzer
let's go
he was the talk of the nba for the last
24 hours and we get to talk to him now
luka doncic joins us
down there from the bubble and uh luca
uh
the emotions of that moment take me
through it from the shot to being mobbed
to being
doused with water afterwards what a what
an experience
oh it was amazing you know a lot of
emotions especially in these playoffs
and obviously when you hit the game
winner you know i said
they asked me the same thing after the
game i said
the best moment was when now when i saw
it go in it's when the whole team like
was
running towards me i think that was very
emotional for me
you know luca when what when did y'all
find out porzinger was not gonna play
i found out uh before the
when they announced starting five you
know i went i went back
uh to the locker room and that's when i
found out and he was like he was very
very sad you know he couldn't be out
there uh he's very important he wants to
play
he wants to be out there and you know
just unfortunate
he's got to work on his knee and that's
that's when i found out
so when you're down 21 in the second
quarter
are you thinking to yourself uh we're in
trouble or i got to be more aggressive
uh
i would never think we're in trouble uh
it's you know it's a lot of game
you know anything can change you know
just i was just talking
uh i said we're gonna win this game you
know we believe uh i think the whole
like i always say you know you got to
believe it and you know we believe from
the beginning
and we came together we started playing
way better defense
and that's just from there we went up
lucas shack here two things first thing
is uh coco
the second thing is um what does that
mean what is that first of all
luca knows i want to know what it means
okay yes how you doing second of all
uh being and being in europe playing in
front of those crowds
uh i've seen videos of those crowds
being tough
is that what gives you the experience to
play in front of you know nba type
crowds and be able to
withstand trash talk you know what i'm
talking about
oh yeah i mean uh there's some really
tough crowds in
uh in europe uh spring especially
uh greece serbia turkey i think those
are the three like really tough
crowds to play in uh it's hard to to to
listen to your teammate right next to
you because they cheers a lot but
uh it's i learned a lot about that you
know uh you gotta trust your teammates
uh you gotta trust your your coaches
everybody on your team you know you're
gonna go together against everybody
and i learned a lot that from in europe
well speaking my native tongue what's
good luca um
this dude over here anyway i i i i said
before the bubble started luca
that there were a couple of guys that i
was really gonna pay close attention to
and yourself
jason tatum and donovan mitchell and i
said i was gonna do that because i felt
that
this is not a continuation of 2020. did
it feel like an off-season and you're
coming back for the next year
knowing more as a player or do you feel
like it's a continuation of 2020
because i felt you were going to come
back as more of an mvp candidate
than an all-star that you won when you
left
i mean i think for me it was like i was
in offseason it was kind of
like second preseason in one season it
was
weird obviously this situation is is not
the
ideal one but you know i felt like it
was we had
another pre-season you know like
working like in the summer
but you know the same mentality as we
start the season we wanted to make the
playoffs
uh now we are tied to two you know uh we
just
we just want to believe we want to want
to win games
and that's what we came here luca this
day on the calendar this
uh august 24th 8 24 it's mamba day
um give me your memories of kobe bryant
and also i mean because i know i've seen
the video of you
you know having a picture taken with
gigi and and
and seeing kobe at the game in in
december
um but i also heard that he was trash
talking you and slovenian
give me that whole story and what your
memories are that night
yeah i mean he said some bad words in my
language you know
uh i was like who's talking to me in my
language you find me and i was like
just look behind me it was kobe so i was
just it was
something amazing you know i would never
forget this this day
and after the game i came you know i
took a picture with him uh
you know he was one of the guys i looked
today
look up to and it was just that day was
amazing and i'll never forget this
you know even though first of all you
were awesome yesterday and we just want
to thank you for sitting in for bob on
tonight
because he was busy i told i told him i
was going to be there and he was pissed
piss you guys hey no we had him on the
other night and he says
i just want to thank you guys for
interviewing me with stella luca it was
awesome
you might be the best guy to interview
luca can you do me one favor
yes say you rang
it up you had to look up that character
because that wasn't going to be
tv i would imagine going up the adams
family but
i would say that you know for the
entertainment that you provided i think
for everyone and you guys are doing in
in generality in the bubble
is the the way you're playing and the
effort that you're playing at and we
understand the stakes it is and how
difficult it is and it's just great to
watch
thank you very much and let me let me
close it out this way with you luca i
i just when i saw yesterday before the
game you and montrez herald together
i think we all appreciated that gesture
um can you tell me about uh
resolving any differences you might have
had over the
that white boy comment oh yeah i mean it
was
like i said you know in the beats
playoffs there's a lot of emotions
i think all the players understand that
you know a lot of
players in this situation don't say the
word they mean you know in the player
there's a lot of
emotions and you know we just clear it
out
and everything's good no worries luca
thank you very much we appreciate your
time uh porzingis going to play
uh the next game i don't know
don't ask me uh let's see i was just
trying to get a little something out of
you
he found out right before the game jack
what are you doing over here man
jack is trying to find out he's trying
to converse with you again
that means good luck right
love your brother hey
lucas thank you much good luck tomorrow
night
we appreciate you man thank you you
ain't got a
an app his language
could we trade shaq to dallas
that was pretty good though we'll be
back